a little more uh
you know calm and uh and a little bit
more light mike tyson's gonna vote
who's he gonna vote for is he gonna vote
is he gonna vote for joe jorgensen
is that is that who he's gonna vote oh
he's going to vote for someone named joe
you think so tell you i used to hang out
with uh
donald trump back in the day we used to
go and pick up ladies and uh
you know he never treated me fairly so
uh i'm going with joe biden
you think that's gonna happen no i can't
see him i can see him voting for
trump tell me why i mean mike dyson's
been punched in the face a couple
maybe two times i don't know where his
mind's at right now so he's gonna go a
little crazy who knows
let's get our audience crazy who do you
think he's voting for
i think he's gonna write in uh the tiger
on the ballot you think so yeah i think
he's gonna vote for the tiger
wow from hangover i like that
i think he's gonna bring in a whole new
candidate by the way i love the way that
mike tyson has reinvented himself yeah
he could have gone the way
of the typical washed up just like angry
beat up you know boxer yeah but he's
you know become more lighthearted
playful pretty incredible sense of humor
about himself
within a split second he can harm
anybody in a room i mean there's only a
couple people in the world that can
probably take this guy
okay you know if he really wanted to in
a room he can do whatever he wants to do
but
you know he's trying to be a good dad he
makes an effort he called that
mayweather he says you think you're
tough he says
tell me if you walk you can't take your
kids to school tell me what you're doing
because this is what i do
tyson's got his own identity right now
and i like it and i think
knowing who he is the underdog guy i
think he's probably
going to be leaning towards voting for
[Music]
trump